I was
uh arrested in Georgia for some dumb
[ __ ] I was wrong place wrong time
friend's house but I got I literally got
charged with two charges of breaking and
entering two charges of criminal
trespassing and then like two felonies
for like Xanax and wax because it's in
Georgia that's what it is so I got all
these goddamn charges for this [ __ ]
that like we were just the wrong place
wrong time and I got basically they
realized that they had [ __ ] up
the local police did so then the judge
gave me a plea deal where like
everything will get dropped except for
one misdemeanor did you get to pick
which one or the judge kept it he kept
it it was it was criminal trespassing I
got I got another one like two years
later in Georgia for breaking into a
tire store that's a whole different so
don't go to George is kind of the place
George is where I where I where I [ __ ]
up yeah anyways I um
I had a good friend from high school who
managed a thrift shop in uh Bozeman
Montana and I was like I need to get
away from all my friends back home
Minnesota they're gonna be like they're
gonna convince me to do drugs or
something so I I just drove out brought
my boy Preston I was like bro you just
come with me and he ended up moving
there after that because it is a
beautiful place yeah but yeah I moved
into this house and he gave us a room
with like three mattresses and then I
realized that we had like people there's
people that would sleep in the back in a
yurt there are people that sleep in the
front in a truck and then we would have
like every room had two people in it so
it was like a little communion we'd have
like Community dinners and everything
and do DMT it was it was beautiful I had
a great time yeah but it sounds great it
was straight up 20 24 days straight I
woke up every day and did 10 hours of
community service
and then went home
and [ __ ] was everybody there doing
community service is it kind of a
halfway house for people doing community
services no no not at all okay it was
literally just a bunch of goons and I I
was the one kid that had to do community
service so they were all going on Hikes
and going on trips and doing all their
cool [ __ ] and I was like every day had
to go to but but here's the thing was
that
part of my plea deal was if you break
any law within the next 18 months until
you're off probation you go to jail for
the rest of 18 months so like if I got a
speeding ticket so that's why I was not
on any I wasn't drinking I wasn't any of
that [ __ ] I just played it safe played
it safe just 10 10 hours a day I'm in a
DMT but other besides that 10 hours a
day community service and what was the
community service you were doing I was
working at thrift shop oh really that's
kind of cool shop it wasn't bad there's
really nice ladies like older which is
every shop in Bozeman I feel like yeah
yeah yeah I did that and then I also did
this was interesting so the uh
he's on like the board of the like one
of the chairs of like the whole city I
don't obviously Billy he was oh a
councilman something like that but he
also owned the local sex shop and it was
like this interesting little combo where
I was like kind of helping out that's a
councilman I was helping out at the sex
shop but I was also
doing like this whole social media promo
for this like suicide prevention walk
and I was dude it was I was just taking
every single hour I could get because I
did not want to go to jail at all that
was like right when I started popping
off with music and I was like dog I
cannot man so do you think it was the
fact that you were popping off with
music that was keeping you out of
staying out of trouble too because you
were like you had finally something
pretty big on the way on the other side
of the scale no I think either way I
would have man like the thought of going
to jail for 18 months was was you didn't
want it I would never yeah now looking
back with being uh a rapper being
entertained you wish you had that jail
time not at all I don't think anyone
would yeah yeah I mean just you mean
like just for like for credibility yeah
just for like just clout just have a
little bit of [ __ ] uh cell clout you
know no no no no I got the charges man
and I beat him I think that's that's
that's so close right there that's a win
that's a win
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one